hey you guys welcome back to my flickers
of fear show so it's getting toward the
end of december and i'm still doing uh
some winter horror movies and this is
one that i've been wanting to see for
quite a while because this is a movie
that came out it's you know it came out
back in 2010 so it's not that new
but it's one that i kind of feel like
its reputation has kind of gotten better
over the years because it didn't do i
mean it kind of made a splash when it
first came out like at the you know when
it was all the festivals and stuff but
then it sort of got overshadowed a
little bit but last couple of years i've
seen it coming up a lot on you know
people's lists of best winter themed
horror movies and this is the 2010 film
frozen yes it's nothing to do with the
disney one and i think maybe
that might have been a part of the
reason why it kind of fell into
obscurity a little bit is just because
the disney frozen is so ubiquitous and i
believe the disney one came out after
this but it's so ubiquitous now that you
can't even if you google frozen
obviously
it's all gonna be the disney movie all
the time so if you want to like google
this and find it you definitely have to
type in like frozen 2010 uh so it
doesn't get confused with the disney one
so that's kind of uh unfortunate how
that happened uh this is nothing like
the disney one by any stretch the
imagination
and i kind of love
this is one of those ones and this i
think i even said this on a couple of my
other uh ones i think when i was talking
about dead end from 2003 if you have a
good premise and you have like some
decent actors and everything is sort of
you know done with the right amount of
suspense and tension and things like
that you don't need a lot of bells and
whistles you don't need a lot of special
effects you don't you know you can go
with a very very simple premise and just
be simple but effective and i think this
is definitely a movie where that really
really comes into play so this was
written and directed by adam green uh
who had previously done the hatchet
movies which we reviewed uh which are
actually really really good if you
haven't seen them uh they're kind of
like sort of like slasher movies uh a
little bit like southern style slasher
movies this is really not like that uh
frozen is kind of more like
a very simple
kind of it's almost kind of like a
bottle moving in the sense it's like one
location it's it's you know people
trapped in one location like i was
talking about the dead end with you know
the family being in a car or like on a
road whereas this one is just kind of
like three friends stuck on a ski lift
and that's pretty much how the movie
goes but
um it's just really really well done so
this is actually more
a survival horror thrill i've seen it
called like oh maybe it's not even a
horror movie it's definitely a horror
movie um but i would call it more like a
survival thriller horror um more than
anything else because everything in this
is
realistic [ __ ] that could happen i've
also seen this compared a lot to
open water that's fair uh open water
pretty much if you haven't seen it was
actually based on a true story about a
couple who were unfortunately uh left
behind when they were out on a cruise or
out on like a scuba diving trip or
something like that they got left behind
out in the middle of the ocean and uh
we're kind of like out there for days
and days and eventually succumbed to
drowning or getting eaten by sharks and
uh it was pretty horrible this is a
pretty horrible story so they didn't
make like a movie about it and this
definitely has
that type of vibe to it even though
obviously it's a different environment
they're not in the ocean they're you
know on this lonely mountain in the in a
snowstorm uh you know trapped up on this
ski lift but
it's kind of the same premise where it's
all the tension kind of comes from
you're not really sure what's going to
happen next and you know them turning
against each other and doing things like
that so as i said this was uh done by
adam green now one of the things that
makes this movie
great is as far as i could determine
from all the research that i did about
the kind of the behind the scenes stuff
i do not think they used any cgi in this
um they actually shot it at a place in i
believe is in utah
and it was
a a ski lift or a you know a ski resort
that was not in use anymore uh but they
still had the lifts there
and uh so they go there and they shot
this you know in
february and march so it was freezing
freezing cold
they actually did sit the actors
50 60 feet off the ground on a ski lift
for hours and hours at a time
and they had to build like all these
cranes and stuff like that to film them
you know while they were going on and
the crew in solidarity with the actors
uh said well if you have to sit up here
for five six hours at a time without
eating or drinking or peeing or anything
uh then we're gonna do the same thing
like while they're filming so everything
in this is real it's funny because i was
watching this other video about it and
they thought it was funny because one of
the criticisms of the movie is like oh
those cgi wolves like ruin it they look
really fake the wolves are not cgi the
wolves are all real uh they actually did
have a wolf trainer
that was there uh you know so he was
wrangling them so those are all actual
wolves you see in there uh the couple
scenes where the wolves get very close
to the actor was that was real um even
though the ones like the attack scenes
like i think that was like a trainer
but other than that pretty much
everything you see
you know so it's not cgi they're they
weren't like sitting on some comfortable
thing with green screen or thing like
that but they actually were sitting up
in that thing for uh you know for hours
at a time in the freezing cold uh and
they had to i think they had to like put
mic like microphones in their hats and
stuff like that just so you could get
all the shots so the fact that they did
all of this stuff oh another great story
too is that they um adam green and like
his crew and stuff they were touring
around like all these different places
because they said well we want a real
ski resort uh because we want this to
look as real as possible
and uh they couldn't really find one
that they liked or they said well we
want the ski lift to be like it has to
be high enough
you know so it seems like dangerous like
perilous but you know they couldn't
really get what they wanted but then
they found this one in utah that like i
said was not really in use anymore and
then they found out that a guy like i
don't remember when this was but uh
several years back a guy had actually
like got on the ski lifts and like shot
himself like committed suicide at this
particular ski resort
and uh they still had the ski lift the
car whatever the uh carriage whatever
you call it and they still had that like
in the you know the lodge or whatever
that had like a bullet hole in it so
they're like as soon as we heard that we
were just kind of like yeah this is
definitely the place where we want to
shoot the horror movie
so essentially so what happens the very
first part of the movie you're setting
up your three main characters and that's
really all there are there are a couple
other uh you know very minor characters
uh actually kane hotter makes a cameo
appearance in this as a guy driving a
snow cat uh he was also in the hatchet
movies in case you didn't know
but yeah he does show up in this one
briefly and uh pretty much all of adam
green's other you know kind of friends
and crew that he works with all the time
a lot of him a lot of them do uh you
know have cameos in this sometimes just
as voices or sometimes like in the
background or whatever
so uh so there's these three friends
it's actually two childhood friends like
two guys their names are dan and joe
and uh apparently you're led to believe
that they've done this uh skiing trip
like all the time so this is a mountain
that they always go to but this time in
particular is different because dan now
has a girlfriend named parker
and so
there's kind of like some simmering
resentment a little bit about even
though it doesn't really come out until
later on until [ __ ] starts to hit the
fan
that
dan that joe is who is single
is kind of like
well you know this was him and dan's
thing this was like their friendship
thing they've been doing it for years
they've known each other since they were
kids and so he kind of sees the
girlfriend as a little bit of an
interloper like into guy time and it
doesn't help too that parker is not
really that good at skiing so on this
particular trip they've had to kind of
stay on the bunny slopes the whole time
and joe's getting really pissed off
about it because he feels like the trip
is kind of ruined because they're just
kind of like having to do this
half-assed
skiing and he wants to like do the real
[ __ ] uh which is one of the things that
leads to
them getting into the situation they get
into now as i said i've seen some
criticism this movie said oh that's you
know that would never happen or you know
it's not realistic or blah blah blah i
was watching this one video that said
you know there was a criticism of you
know the way that they get left on the
on the ski lift they're like oh that
would never happen but then like a
couple years later or a couple weeks
later actually as the movie came out
that actual thing did happen
so
the way that it happens in the movie
completely plausible um you know what i
mean it's just like a series of
unfortunate things that happen so what
they do because you know they've had to
be on the bunny slopes all day and joe's
pissed off about it he's like well let's
just do one more it's sunday night uh
this is a this is a ski resort like uh i
guess a lot of them are i don't know you
know i don't know i live in florida we
don't have snow or mountains here either
but some resorts are only open on the
weekends they're only open from friday
to sunday and they stay closed during
the week and uh that's what this one is
so it's sunday night and they're like
they're closing up but they're actually
closing up early because there's a bad
storm coming but they managed to kind of
persuade the guy who's you know managing
the lift he's like please just let us do
one more one more run it's like we won't
tell anybody and so they get on the lift
the guy's like okay fine just you know
just go
now the guy does actually radio to the
other guy because he's going off shift
and he radios the other guy oh there's
three people still up there let them
finish their run
so he does tell them that it's not that
he just like forgot or whatever
but what ends up happening is when the
new guy comes on shift there's actually
these three other people that comes like
snowboarding down the hill and he
thought that those were the three people
that he was talking about he didn't
realize that people were still on the
lift
so that's how it ends up happens like i
said it's pretty [ __ ] plausible which
is actually pretty terrifying so
essentially they're like well it's
sunday night no one's gonna be back
until friday you know when the lodge
opens again so uh so these three people
are still on the ski lift and they're
over
it's probably i think it's like 50 or 60
feet like to the ground
and they're stuck there so all the
power's out uh you know everybody's gone
home and uh they're in big [ __ ]
trouble
so that's pretty much how the rest of
the movie goes is just them trying to
figure out
how to survive um you know how they're
gonna get down from here without
freezing to death or breaking their
bones or anything like that like how to
get down so uh you know like i said it
sounds like a very simple premise but
just the way it kind of like ramps up it
kind of reminded me i guess because i
just watched this movie and then i kind
of got back into watching that oh that
show that used to be on cable like i
shouldn't be alive and i was like this
is this movie seems like something this
seems like an episode of that show but i
mean that like in a flattering kind of
way uh it is kind of like that because
it's just kind of like these three
people
and
like i said they don't only have to
contend with being high up and they
can't really climb they can't really
jump down because it's too far but they
also have to contend with there's a
blizzard there's a snowstorm
you know they're freezing uh they can't
they don't have any food they don't have
any water uh you know they can't go to
the bathroom obviously and it's you know
and it's gonna be probably almost a week
before somebody shows up and obviously
they're going to die before that happens
so fairly early on uh dan
decides well you know i i can make that
jump i can jump and uh you know i'll go
get help you know before it gets too
late because because we're gonna die if
somebody doesn't do something this
doesn't uh really go very well and
honestly i was reading
when this movie first premiered at some
of the uh some of the you know horror
movie festivals and stuff that actually
some people had really been like
freaking out at this or like you know
passing out and stuff i know some of
that is maybe like hype and everything
uh but this did actually get a lot of
word of mouth for being
very
intense uh and it definitely is it's not
the most intense movie i've ever seen
but some of the stuff in here i guess
because it's so realistic and you could
imagine being in that situation and how
bad it would suck uh so i could see how
like you know the the tension like
ramping up it is like pretty intense and
it pretty much starts when dan
tries to jump down from the lift
and
the scene of his
spoiler alert the scene of his legs
breaking
is
pretty gnarly uh i have to say so he's
down there he can't move his legs are
basically just like completely [ __ ]
the bones are sticking out and
everything and it's just it's really
nasty that's bad enough both his legs
are broken it's freezing cold uh he
can't move
uh but then there are some other
things that happen that maybe you
wouldn't even think about because it
wouldn't be the first thing you'd think
about and that would be wolves so
and him being in pain not being able to
move and being covered with blood and
stuff like that uh you know that goes
about as well as you'd expect so uh so
as i said so basically the rest of the
movie is them trying to figure out like
how to get down and just horrible
horrible [ __ ] happening to frostbite
like uh you know parker's hand like
freezes to the safety pole like when she
dozes off it's just like horrible
horrible [ __ ] happens like they uh you
know joe tries to climb down on the cord
that it's like to the next because i
guess like on the ski lifts they have
like poles and the poles have ladders on
them obviously so people can get up and
down like to maintain the lift and so he
wants to
kind of take the the cord like back to
the or the uh the zip line whatever the
hell you call it uh the line back to you
know a couple cars back so he can climb
down uh but you know obviously those
lines are not the cables rather are
sharp uh so they cut through his gloves
and it's like now his hands are all
[ __ ] up and he can't
really do it anymore so it's like all
these kind of things that
sort of conspire to and obviously
they're getting tired and dehydrated and
freezing cold and it's just a not a good
situation all around and then they start
turning on one another um you know it's
you know it's your fault that we're here
you know if we if you hadn't made us be
on the bunny slopes all day you know we
would have had a good run and we would
have gone home and all this other kind
of [ __ ] and honestly
one interesting thing about this is that
when i was first watching it because
like i said
up until like it's probably like it's
not a super long movie i think it's like
maybe less than 90 minutes
but beginning part i'm i'm not gonna say
the characters are unlikable they're not
but um they're not super likable either
but an interesting thing that happened
at least for me like while i was
watching the movie is that as their
situation got more and more dire i
started feeling
a lot more bad for them you know what i
mean even though at first i was just
kind of like these people are kind of
douchey you know what i mean am i really
gonna care like you know what i mean if
they like get stuck up with a ski lift
to die
but
i was actually surprised that after
because like i said i guess that's just
like a human reaction because you get
you know you're watching these people in
this horrible situation that's just
getting worse and worse and you can
empathize with because you're like oh my
god what if that was me like what if i
was in that situation what the [ __ ]
would you do and it'd be horrible and i
think what another thing that helped too
was
when they started kind of opening up to
one another and one scene in particular
where uh parker was talking about how
she had just got a puppy like for
christmas a month or two before and
she's like you know what the puppies in
my apartment like buys and i'm the only
one that has keys and the puppy's going
to think that i left him
and he's not going to understand that i
died he's not going to understand what
happened to me and he's going to starve
to death and i was just kind of like
because you know anything with animals
i'm going to get like way more upset
about that than i have about people so
that like really bummed me out because
i'm like oh my god like i can't even
imagine like that poor little dog i felt
like worse for the dog for a second but
yeah so there was like this whole thing
and like
you know joe getting kind of like mad at
her but then they sort of like got their
[ __ ] together and he was trying to like
be more heroic and him talking about
like kind of opening up about why he was
still single and stuff like that so
there's like a lot of psychological
stuff going on too so i feel like the
characters get more likeable as the
movie goes on and you actually you know
you don't want to see something bad
happen to them even though at the
beginning you're kind of like well at
least i was just kind of like you know i
don't know if i'm going to be
if i'm going to be fully invested in
this because i didn't think the
characters were all that likable but
as it goes on uh i really started
feeling bad for them and then like when
bad [ __ ] i was like oh man oh no so i
did kind of like get invested but it
took a little while you know what i mean
so because they weren't immediately
likable they weren't unlikable either i
don't want to say that but you know they
were vaguely douchey but i guess like in
a normal person douchey kind of way like
the way normal people are douchey so
they kind of came across like that but
it wasn't as
i don't know it like i said it wasn't
like a slasher movie where it was just
like oh my god just please die all of
you you know what i mean it wasn't like
that but
um yeah they definitely did get more
sympathetic like as the movie went on
but yeah so this movie um you can
actually watch it for free on to be at
least as of this recording
uh in december of 2021 and it's totally
worth watching uh especially if you like
survival horror uh or you know anything
winter themed this is something that
could conceivably happen and has
happened um you know so so there's that
whole thing and it's just you know it's
kind of a man versus nature uh type
thing but it's just it's so simple the
premise of it and it's just like i said
it just goes to show that you don't need
to have all this elaborate brew haha to
make a simple effective
horror film and like i said some of the
[ __ ] that happens is like the dude's
legs breaking and it's like it's just so
nasty like and honestly i couldn't even
it's stuff like that bothers me more
than just like real overt gore i guess
like because if you go like super the
top with gore like people getting
chopped in half or you know chopped down
the front or something that's just like
funny in a way
but when it's something that's realistic
like somebody jumping down from a great
height and their legs like busting
that's like really hard to watch and i
think a lot of people have find that
really hard to watch because like i said
it's realistic i mean and you could
imagine that happening to you like with
that horrible sound and all this other
stuff and then you're laying there going
well [ __ ] me like now my legs are like
this and then all these wolves are like
ooh dinner you know what i mean so
it's kind of like oh it's like this
really shitty situation and then you're
like oh well if that does happen i'm
gonna freeze to death i'm just gonna be
sitting up here
i [ __ ] popsicle you know after a week
and it's just like a horrifying it's
just a horrifying idea but but you know
like i said so
i feel like it got kind of a lot of buzz
when it came out
you know uh when it did all the round of
all the festivals and i think it got a
small theatrical release i think it made
i think it made less than three million
dollars i don't know how much it costs
to make not that much um because like i
said all the effects are practical
there's as far as i know there's not any
cgi in this at all
but it was kind of a grueling
shoot because you know uh they did shoot
it in freezing cold conditions on an
actual mountain on an actual ski lift uh
with actual wolves so you know so so you
get it really does come across that i
guess that the actors were
in the crew were going through the same
thing that the characters were going
through so i think that really did help
give it some you know very similitude
but yeah um if you're really into winter
horror movies if you really like
survival type stuff like i said if you
like open water this is similar a
similar kind of vibe i guess even though
it's a completely different environment
but it's a similar kind of thing going
on so if you liked that uh then
definitely check this one out because i
feel like it's a little bit underrated
like i said if you're gonna search for
it they have it on tubey uh but search
frozen 2010 because otherwise you're
just gonna get pages of pages of disney
stuff with olaf and all that so uh so
you know just just keep that in mind but
yeah definitely check it out on tubey or
if you've seen it uh let me know if you
liked it if you didn't like it uh you
know let's talk about it in the comments
and that will do it for this flickers of
fear i will see you guys on the next one
bye